Hello, hello. Uh this is Yumi and this
is my inner voice.
Yumi stands for you and me.
And together we are going to reprogram
how we and especially how our opponents
approach the game of EDH. Now many EDH
players, including this guy, draw a hard
line with politics and group hug.
Understandably because with this play
style it's very easy to fall into a
slippery slope and turn the game into
some kind of uncontrolled chaos. But I
sure have many have wondered is it
possible through thoughtful design and
consistent enforcement to create rules
within the game that your play group
will know how to follow and be happy to.
Sometimes. For example, there was some
brainstorming for an Oko EDH deck that
will do everything it can to one shot
the player who takes monarch from her.
And that attempt to add an unspoken rule
to the game makes sense because of the
double efficiency when attacking the
monarch. But with what we have, there is
potential for so much more. Now assist
has always been an awkward and messy
mechanic in multiplayer because
technically you're supposed to choose
one person, show them the card you plan
to cast, and they can choose to help you
pay anywhere between zero to all of the
generic mana cost. But in EDH this
becomes a back and forth. I reveal a
spell, who wants to pay for it, how much
do you want to pay? Oh, you're paying
three. Well, Billy here is willing to
pay 12 to blow everything up. But Billy
is already ahead. How do How about you
pay four so we can blow his stuff up
first? So you see this kind of
discussion is a mostly inherent and
unavoidable part of playing this
mechanic. But it can be annoying and
very time consuming. Now there is a
perfect solution. But the problem is
this perfect solution is likely
different for every play group and you
will have to fine tune every detail to
find the sweet spot where your play
group will be willing to comply with
your shenanigans. And the solution I
found is what I call Yumi's General
Store. Yeah, just a happy, friendly
cornerstone to the community, but with
some slightly more sinister plans when
the doors are closed. And having tested
this with two different groups, I have
to say this is the most unique and
refreshing experience I've ever had
playing EDH. And this is no
exaggeration, I promise, and you will
see why. Well, the first rule is that
the shop is always open for as long as
I'm on the battlefield and not a 3/3 elk
with no abilities. Thanks, Jerry. And
what that means is my hand will be
revealed to everyone. Not just the
goods, either. Every card, even the
secret tricks that are not for sale. And
this is so that my opponent my consumers
can plan ahead on what they wish to
purchase. And when my turn comes,
everyone who wishes to can submit a bid,
and I will choose which one to accept,
usually the highest bid. Simple as that.
Maybe I'll throw out a counter offer
once in a while, but but we want to keep
the process as simple and efficient as
possible. Pick your product, pay, and
get the out of my face. Now, if no
one wants to buy anything, that's that's
okay, too. I'll just play Magic
normally, and that's pretty much the
entire rule that I'm adding to this
game. There will be some terms and
conditions and maybe special promos once
in a while, but for the most part it's
pretty straightforward. You pick a
spell, you get to target anything I
don't control, and in some occasions,
say if you want to pay the full cost or
say seven out of nine mana for a Bogle,
but sure, you can control the first two
chapters. Why not? But for the most
part, you want to keep the process as
simple and consistent as possible. Okay,
and now that the shopping guideline has
been established, we are picking our
inventory. And this is something we have
to be very careful about because the
biggest problem with Group Hug is with
these constant effects that your
opponents can just run away with and you
have no way to shut down. So, often
times you're just king making, and the
rich gets richer. So, the first
condition is that our cards need to be
one use, like a removal, a one-off draw
spell, or one little extra turn. The key
is that these benefits can be handed out
in a controlled fashion by me. So, yeah,
a lot of the top picks like Howling
Mine, Helm of Awakening, Font of Mythos,
wow, two cards a turn. Yeah, these are
not going to be in. This is not a deck
you should use EDHREC for. On top of
that, I want my products to have an
initial impact, but also can stick
around and generate some value for me so
that I am not completely defenseless in
these trying times. A great example of
this is the planeswalkers. Elspeth, the
wanderer. Now, these are board wipes.
They're a bit overcosted for the effect,
but our lovely customers are paying for
that. The same goes with the sagas or
even just big creatures with an ETB
effect so that I can defend myself with
them. And finally, I want big,
high-impact cards. Because from my
experience in the early game, people are
not usually that interested in buying.
They do their own stuff, but later on,
you know, when things get tight, if
someone runs away with the game or when
someone is desperate for cards, that's
when they will pay. Also, we're avoiding
the "Why can't you pay for it yourself?"
allegations, because I can't. This is
nine mana. So, that sums up our thought
process in picking the products. Again,
these are just what I came up with. The
idea is that first of all, you don't
want to be king-making, and second of
all, you get to keep something for
yourself always. So, now we understand
how the deck works. Let's take a look at
our selection. First of all, we have a
ton of removals, because this is what
fits our criteria best. You know, these
creatures that enter, deal with
something, and leave behind a large
body. Yeah, this is the most
straightforward way to ensure that we
have a win-win transaction. And some of
these are more than just a large body,
like Captain Marvel, like Cityscape
Leveler. You can continue to use the
removal effect when the dust settles.
Now, will your opponent be hesitant to
pay for these? Because, you know, the
attack trigger might come at them. Yes,
it's possible, so you will have to
fine-tune and adjust your products based
on the play style or the personality of
your playgroup. And for the sagas, you
want the first chapter to be the most
relevant, the strongest, so your
opponents would want to buy that, and
you can secretly benefit from the
remaining chapters. Another great one is
Portal to Phyrexia. Yeah, people
probably won't buy that unless they're
desperate, but from my experience, there
are a lot of desperate times in EDH. So,
yeah, those are the removals for sale.
And after that is board wipes. I do have
Ugin and Farewell as kind of the panic
button that we can press together. Yes,
this deck I'm trying to place at bracket
three because I feel like it's kind of
it's able to self-adjust a little bit.
If for some reason you are way more
powerful than the table, people are not
going to work with you. But if you're
falling behind, people are more inclined
to reach out and seek some mutual
benefits. So yeah, bracket two, bracket
three, I think we'll do fine in both.
For the rest of the board wipes, we are
playing all the ones that can keep you
me around. Tragic arrogance is another
example where you can adjust the cost.
Like if you pay three, sure maybe you
can choose some of the permanence you
keep. And if you just pay one, I'll be
doing a deep cleaning on the board. But
that's that. Removals are boring,
especially I'm I'm worried that maybe
I'm playing too many board wipes, but
those are the cards that really fit our
restriction and game plan. So I will do
more testing and see how it goes. But
now we move on to the variety aisle and
this is all kinds of weird wacky stuff
you can sell. Ooh, is that a tentacle?
Well, Yumi knows where this is going.
But before that, I want to present you
with some truly special products. Some
you can even get for free. And that is
stack boxes and accessories from
Kakapopo TCG. They've got a lot of
designs influenced by the Japanese
aesthetic, which is perfect for dressing
up Yumi. If these look good to you, take
a look at Kakapopo TCG's website and use
my discount code for 5% off. Also, you
can get these deck boxes for free if you
enter the giveaway by subscribing and
commenting or double your chance by
commenting a card that I end up adding
to the deck. I'll keep a list down in
the pin comment so that you can see
what's been suggested, what hasn't.
Anyways, back to the game. Another way
that white likes to make deals is
through card draw. Secret rendezvous,
cut a deal, these are simple but
effective. Also, the war in triad allows
you to sell mana. Yeah, help me pay for
this now and you will get an extra mana
on your turn. Pendant of prosperity,
this kind of goes against what I said
earlier, our our policies for product
selection, but this card on paper is
just so amazing and I never got to use
it effectively and it seems perfect
here. Just give it to the struggling
player and profit. Yeah, I want to try
this. And it gets crazier from here.
First of all, white is excellent at
reanimating, but only if you're doing it
also for someone else. So, something
like Jailbreak, Immortal Obligation, and
Dawn Bringer Reclaimer. These will sell
like hotcakes. Benevolent Offering, just
a nice little modal spell. We can sell
the tokens, we can sell the life gain,
or both if the price is right. Canoptek
Scarab Swarm, if you really need that
graveyard hated, yeah, we can do that
for you. I do get a few blockers though.
Archangel of Strife is a crazy one. I'm
not sure here because it can backfire. I
am playing a few cycle lands just in
case it goes out of hand, but I can see
some scenarios where this is pretty fun,
so we'll try it. Yozei, the Morning
Star, another reason for those cycle
lands, if we really want to lock someone
down, I've got you. Now, we're heading
towards the top shelf with Overwhelming
Splendor.
Yeah, this card is brutal, especially
when I don't have to pay for it. And
finally, we reach the top-tier, the
status symbol level products. Most of my
viewers don't even get to see this. Only
the ones that have endured me yapping
for 9 minutes. That's right, we are
selling extra turns. Perch Protection, I
love this card so much, and it embodies
this deck perfectly. But now, we open
the final door to our backrooms, and
there she is, Emrakul. It's always
Emrakul. This is actually so versatile.
Together, you can control someone's
turn. Or if someone's willing to pay
enough, they can use the extra turn for
themselves. And while we're here, Rise
of the Eldrazi, why not? You pay some
mana, say four or five, you can choose
to blow up something and draw five
cards, including the one from Yummy. And
meanwhile, I refresh on top, act like I
didn't just ruin someone's day, and
that's it for our products. However, I
can't have my entire deck be for sale.
This was a difficult lesson I learned
when playing with my group. At first,
they were positive, thrilled even, about
the idea of Yummy's shop. But as the
game went on, I began hearing murmurs
about what Baldur's Gate? Huh.
What happens in Baldur's Gate? Oh, okay.
Yeah, that was rough. So, I decided I
can't just be one of those oblivious
merchants you can just kill, rob, or
even have sex with. Yummy is strictly
against violence and theft. So, we need
a set of cards that can protect
ourselves, but also works well with our
game plan. Yeah, remember our game plan
of showing everything? The natural
conclusion is cheap instant speed spot
removals. Yeah, you know how they made a
bunch of these Path to Exile side grades
and downgrades? We are playing all of
them. They're cheap enough so we can
hold them up at all times and threaten
to use them between the bigger
transactions we make. And with our hand
constantly revealed, hopefully these can
serve as a deterrent, urging people to
work with us rather than against us. And
finally, we have a few ramp pieces.
These are pretty important, but I don't
want to go crazy with them cuz mono
white already struggles when it comes to
gas. Some choices here include the new
Gleaming Splendor and Tatterdemalion.
But aside from this, there is an
underlying secret plan. And that is
building up our mana base. Because
eventually we'll have to face off
against, hopefully one opponent, but
sometimes multiples when they decide to
turn on you. And when that happens, I
want to be able to play my big spells
without help multiple times a turn. And
the secret to achieving that is between
the selling and smiles and customer
service, I'm secretly building my land
base revolving around Cloudpost. We got
the Wayfarer, the maps to kind of slowly
assemble the pieces. I'm not playing
Urza's because I find them to be far
less reliable and they don't work well
with copy lands. But I do have stuff
like, you know, Ancient Tomb, Temple of
the False God as backup. Now, that sums
up the deck. Now, unlike most other
decks, the card choices is not the focus
here, but how you play it. Once again, I
try to keep it simple with, you know,
your hand revealed, people can bid.
That's fun. But if you usually play with
a familiar group, you can continue to
add little rules or little twists and
constantly adjust to find, again, that
perfect sweet spot. For example, if you
attack me, the spells cost more for you
to buy. You'll lose the chance to do
business with me for two turns when I
reopen. Or you can just do something
completely different than what I'm doing
here. I'm just suggesting one of the
infinite possibilities you can do. You
have to figure out what is right and
when you do, you're going to have the
best time playing EDH. Now, trust me, I
I hate group hug, but this deck has been
a blast. The deck is pretty slow, not
the most resilient, but what's great
about it is if you build and play it
right, it should be self-adjusting to
any power level between bracket two and
three. And that's a pretty big range.
And unfortunately, in mono white, you
kind of have to pay premium in terms of
money for a lot of the utility. So, this
deck isn't very budget-friendly. But
yet, at the end, I'm just going to leave
all of the store policies that's been
working with my group for your
consideration. That's all. Thank you so
much for watching my video. This is
Yummy with Next Level Magic. And please
like [music] and subscribe for more
content, and we will see you in the next
video.
>> Yummy no mise arigato.
Yummy no mise arigato.